[Musique]
bonjour à tous très heureux de vous
retrouver pour un nouveau numéro de
Parlement Hebdo l'émission qui revient
sur l'actualité de la semaine au
Parlement et aujourd'hui nous
accueillons Prisca théveno bonjour
député renaissance des Hauts-de-Seine
merci d'être avec nous pour commenter
l'actualité intense de cette semaine et
cette semaine une bomination massive
s'est organisée contre la réforme des
retraites avec ce jeudi entre 1 million
et 2 millions de personnes dans la rue
une nouvelle journée de mobilisation est
prévue pour le mardi 31 janvier le Sénat
a examiné cette semaine le projet loi
qui accélère la construction de nouveaux
réacteurs nucléaire la majorité de
droite du Sénat a supprimé l'objectif
qui limitait la part du nucléaire dans
notre mix énergétique et puis à
l'Assemblée nationale les députés ont
adopté à l'unanimité la proposition de
loi créant une aide financière d'urgence
pour les victimes de violence conjugales
la mobilisation était donc au
rendez-vous ce jeudi 19 janvier plus
d'un million de manifestants selon les
chiffres de la police 2 millions dit à
la CGT des parlementaires étaient dans
le cortège des parlementaires de gauche
écouter ses réactions recueillies au
cœur de la manif parisienne par Fabien
rekker Jonathan du prière avec Cécile
even
85% des Français sont hostiles à cette
réforme et donc qu'il est encore temps
de reculer de comprendre que quand on
gouverne on ne gagne pas contre son pays
au gouvernent pour lui notamment pour
celles et ceux qui sont les plus
fragiles le fait d'être paru peu peser
peu peser et faire en sorte que cette
réforme soit retirée en tout cas c'est
notre objectif on va contribuer à ce
qu'il en soit ainsi je pense que c'est
pas une question d'une unité de la
gauche du nom de la gauche c'est une
question de colère des gens et ça ils
pourront faire des petits amendements et
pour en rajouter une virgule ici ou un
amendement là ça changera strictement
rien à cette colère nous ne voulons pas
travailler plus la question c'est est-ce
qu'on veut se projeter Macron borne et
c'est aussi la réponse est non et c'est
pour ça que les gens sont la rue il y a
je rappelle qu'il y a quelques il y a
deux ans de cela il y avait déjà un
projet de réforme de la retraite portée
à l'époque par Édouard Philippe et
Emmanuel Macron bon ben on a on a gagné
le bras de fer c'est un bras de fer il
faut commencer à l'entamer en pour
gagner alors il y a eu en tout entre 1
et 2 millions de personnes dans dans la
rue selon les chiffres est-ce que vous
reconnaissez Prisca théveno la forte
mobilisation qu'il a eu ce jeudi contre
la réforme est-ce que vous assumez de
faire une réforme impopulaire
alors est-ce qu'il y a eu une
mobilisation ce jeudi oui il y a eu une
mobilisation maintenant rappelons que
cette mobilisation quel est son enjeu
cette mobilisation c'est effectivement
une expression une expression qui est
absolument légitime de revendications
mais c'est revendications si elles se
sont exprimées ce jeudi elles ont pu
aussi être entendues portées à
différents autres moments les voix se
sont également entendues pendant les
élections présidentielles pendant les
élections législatives également au
cours des concertations et des
consultations qui ont été menées par le
gouvernement avec Elisabeth borne
notamment et Olivier du soft et puis
elles vont se poursuivre elles vont se
poursuivre à l'Assemblée nationale en
commission et j'insiste sur en
commission et ensuite dans l'hémicycle
et donc ces voix pour s'exprimer il ne
faut qu'elle ne qu'aucune ne soit
oubliée donc oui il y a eu une
manifestation vous voulez d'ailleurs
qu'on vous prenait en compte il faut
tout attendre il faut tout entendre je
pense que au-delà de la colère il faut
entendre les demandes les demandes qui
sont légitimes des demandes qui peuvent
être aussi du ressort de l'angoisse de
la peur parce qu'on parle quelque chose
d'important du moment de notre retraite
mais attention à ne pas venir tout
résumer en un bruit de certains
politiques écoutons les Français ne
transformons pas ce débat de société en
un débat simplement entre politique
alors en tout cas beaucoup de Français
ont manifesté et à certains aussi fait
grève la grève a été très suivie ce
jeudi et elle se poursuivra dans
certains secteurs à partir de lundi
est-ce que vous craignez un blocage du
pays non je crains un blocage du débat
et ce ça c'est je suis très très ferme
dessus nous devons pouvoir avoir un
débat sur ce sujet mais vous savez
derrière ces manifestations qu'on a pu
avoir jeudi il faut aussi entendre la
demande l'expression beaucoup plus
générale qui va même au-delà de la
réforme des retraites en réalité parce
que ce qu'on peut entendre c'est
différentes revendications sur des
points que nous devons aussi pouvoir
traiter un sujet sur l'équité ce
sentiment d'injustice qui est très
important et très présent auquel nous
devons répondre de façon très légitime
et claire il y a aussi ce sujet figure
le rapport au travail qui a changé
aujourd'hui on ne considère plus que
réussir sa vie c'est réussir sa carrière
et je dois dire que c'est très bien nous
devons être maintenant sur un rapport au
travail plus juste et enfin peut-être le
plus important dans le cadre actuel de
ces manifestations que nous avons eu
jeudi le rapport au dialogue social ce
dialogue social aujourd'hui doit être
capable de se réinventer parce
qu'aujourd'hui on a l'impression qu'elle
se dialogue social n'a eu lieu que dans
le cadre de ces manifestations c'est
faux nous l'avons dit différents
concertations consultations ont eu lieu
il ne faut pas l'oublier et je dois dire
aussi qu'il y a aussi deux nouvelles
instances de dialogues sociales qui sont
par exemple le Conseil national de leur
affondation ou les grands débats mais si
jamais le mouvement s'amplifie
s'accentue et que vous êtes en train de
siéger dans l'hémicycle vous avez 20
jours pour étudier ce projet de loi sur
les retraites si le mouvement s'amplifie
ce que vous êtes prêt à prendre en
compte les demandes dans la rue est-ce
que vous êtes prêts aussi à négocier
avec à discuter avec les autres forces
d'opposition par exemple à prendre des
amendements venus de la gauche ou pas
est-ce que le dialogue est possible le
dialogue est déjà là et il est déjà
présent est-ce que nous sommes prêts à
prendre en compte l'ensemble des
demandes et des ambitions des Français
pour le moment de leur retraite oui et
c'est justement la raison même de cette
volonté de faire cette réforme parce que
ce que j'entends aussi beaucoup et qu'on
oublie peut-être c'est que nous voulons
continuer à être une nation solidaire
nous voulons continuer à être cette
nation qui fait attention à ses aînés
qui prend soin de celles et ceux qui ont
participé à l'effort de construction
souvent de reconstruction de notre pays
et donc nous devons pouvoir aujourd'hui
mais tout en oeuvre en tant que
politique et là il notre responsabilité
et en tant que parlementaire de la
majorité vous savez tout à fait raison
proposer des amendements pour améliorer
certains points et au-delà même des
amendements je pense que l'enjeu c'est
d'avoir tous les sujets sur la table
ensuite on verra ça fera l'objet
d'amendement ou pas mais nous devons
pouvoir mettre tous les sujets sur la
table au sein de la majorité
présidentielle vous avez par exemple le
modem François Bayrou qui est plutôt
favorable à une hausse des cotisations
patronales a aussi un effort de
l'employeur dans ce rééquilibrage de
notre régime des retraites vous avez
certains députés Renaissance qui fassent
à ce report de l'âge légal de départ 10
pour l'instant on ne va pas voter le
texte est-ce que la majorité
présidentielle peut craquer
la majorité présidentielle reste unie et
soudée sur le principe que nous devons
maintenir notre système de retraite qui
a un système de retraite par répartition
nous y tenons extrêmement
fort et je le dis d'autant plus à titre
personnel que je suis issue de la gauche
je ne me vois pas des tricoter ce
système de solidarité
intergénérationnelle maintenant tout ce
que vous venez de dire sont des
revendications tout à fait légitimes il
y en a d'autres sur d'autres bancs nous
devons pouvoir les étudier et les
traiter j'ai envie de dire au sein des
instances démocratiques donc en
commission envisageable après ça dépend
quel modèle on veut ça dépend quel
modèle on veut c'est pour ça que il
s'agit pas simplement de lancer des
totems et d'opposer des tabous il s'agit
de décrire la société que nous voulons
nous voulons aujourd'hui une société où
chacun peut trouver un travail juste un
travail rémunéré qui lui permettra
d'aller en retraite dans une dans des
conditions physiques correctes et bien
pour qu'on puisse continuer à être un
pays qui faisons de l'emploi qui créons
du travail et ben nous devons accepter
aussi que nous devons ne pas continuer à
imposer de façon extrêmement forte les
entreprises qui d'ailleurs qui
d'ailleurs participent déjà au
financement de nos retraites c'est faux
de dire qu'elle n'y participe pas avec
le pacte social avec la C3S avec un
certain nombre d'impositions sur les
sociétés elles y participent des gens
extrêmement fortes pour vous ce n'est
pas une réforme pour financière pour
réduire le déficit public c'est aussi
une réforme sociale c'est ce que vous
dites c'est une réforme
pour baisser le déficit vous avez raison
c'est une réforme d'équilibre
d'équilibre budgétaire dans le
financement même de ce système mais
aussi une réforme d'équilibre social
parce qu'il est aujourd'hui complètement
faux et mensongé de dire que le système
aujourd'hui tel qu'il existe et une
panacée ce n'est pas vrai je le dis en
tant que femme les carrières féminines
ne sont pas assez bien prises en compte
je l'ai dit aussi en tant qu'enfant
d'ouvriers les carrières longues et
pénibles ne sont pas assez bien prises
en compte lesquels les carrières
également qui sont hachés par exemple
les procédants elles ne sont pas assez
bien rendre compte nous devons pouvoir y
répondre on va parler d'un autre sujet
on va parler du nucléaire puisque cette
semaine le Sénat a examiné le projet loi
du gouvernement qui accélère la
construction de nouveaux réacteurs
nucléaire alors la majorité de droite du
Sénat et favorable à ce texte mais elle
y a apporté des modifications notamment
en supprimant l'objectif de limiter la
part du nucléaire dans notre mix
énergétique les explications de Marion
Vigreux
au départ c'est un texte technique qui
arrive au Sénat un texte qui vient fixer
et simplifier les procédures permis de
construire autorisation environnementale
nécessaire pour entamer le plus
rapidement possible les projets de
futures réacteurs EPR 2 il est important
car il permettra d'accélérer les
procédures administratives de
construction de nouveaux réacteurs
électronucléaires dans notre pays avec
deux objectifs
raccourcir les délais de réalisation de
ces projets de plusieurs années et
contribuer à en baisser le coût pour les
consommateurs mais c'est sans compter
sur les sénateurs qui estiment en
majorité que le gouvernement légifère
dans le désordre en s'attardant sur des
points techniques alors que la stratégie
même n'a pas encore été fixée on ne peut
pas débattre
sérieusement sur la question nucléaire
ça a d’avoir défini une stratégie quel
mix électrique etc etc et après on aura
des débats et peut-être des désaccords
et des divergences mais une fois qu'on
aura tranché ça la majorité c'est natale
donc choisi d'intégrer à ce projet de
loi l'article 1 dédié spécifiquement à
la relance du nucléaire et qui fait
sauter deux points majeurs la fermeture
de 12 réacteurs et la limitation à 50%
de nucléaires dans le mix électrique en
2035 nous ne préomptons pas le débat
public parce que les 50% ils pourront
devenir peut-être 75 et c'est peut-être
la préférence de ce côté-ci du de
l'hémicycle mais ils pourront peut-être
devenir vain et ça sera peut-être la
possibilité ici nous ne préomptons pas
nous rend simplement nous disons les 50%
c'est obsolète et nous accompagnons les
mesures techniques par une vision
politique du côté du ministère de la
transition énergétique on estime que
c'est un mauvais coup politique et que
cet amendement n'a rien à faire dans ce
projet technique la stratégie tant
réclamée étant prévu pour cet été lors
de l'examen au Parlement de la loi de
programmation énergique climat
on l'a vu dans ce débat il y a des
petites discordances entre le
gouvernement et les sénateurs sur le
calendrier mais quand la droite du Sénat
supprime cet objectif qui limitait à 50
% la part du nucléaire dans notre mix
énergétique finalement c'est cohérent
avec le programme d'Emmanuel Macron qui
veut relancer cette filière nucléaire je
pense qu'il faut rappeler l'objectif de
ce texte et c'est sur ça qu'il faut
qu'on s'attache pour ne pas nous tromper
et avoir une position claire ce texte ce
n'est pas une loi de programmation
énergétique c'est un texte de
facilitation administrative ça a été
rappelé par la ministre Agnès la loi de
programmation arrivera en son temps
faisons les choses étape par étape ne
confondant pas des olives le dire mais à
vitesse et précipitations puisque nous
nous prendrons les pieds dans le tapis
collectivement et ne nous trompons pas
d'objectif oui nous voulons être sur un
mix énergétique entre énergie
renouvelable et nucléaire mais ce mix
énergétique n'est pas une finalité une
modalités une modalité pourquoi pour
être une nation souveraine indépendante
dans une ligne de décarbonation assumée
et revendiqué effectivement par Emmanuel
Macron alors justement quand on voit le
coup d'une centrale le père de flamants
ville c'est plus de 20 milliards d'euros
et le temps de construction est très
long est-ce que pour vous dans ce
contexte
l'énergie nucléaire est toujours une un
secteur d'avenir l'énergie le nucléaire
la filière du nucléaire est une filière
et voilà la filière nucléaire est une
filière d'excellence française dont nous
devons être fiers maintenant est-ce que
il est vrai que pendant longtemps et
bien nous avons pas assez fait la
promotion de cette filière notamment je
parle en termes de formation pour nos
jeunes pour les générations et donc nous
avons manqué aussi de se renouveau pour
venir combler pour venir alimenter cette
filière d'excellence française oui c'est
en fait est-ce que nous prenons acte de
cela et nous allons avancer dans cette
démarche là oui tout à fait nous devons
rappeler que ces filières sont des
filières sur lesquelles nous devons
continuer à mettre des jeunes en
apprentissage en formation pour les
orienter vers ces versets alors la
majorité de droits du Sénat a profité de
ce texte pour faire voter un amendement
à qui triple la peine de prison pour
notamment les activistes écologistes qui
s'introduisent dans les installations
nucléaires est-ce que se durcissement
n'est pas un peu excessif je pense que
il n'y a jamais assez c'est pas excessif
de dire que nous devons respecter
aujourd'hui la loi je pense que plus que
jamais aujourd'hui nous devons être
ferme avec celles et ceux qui a tort et
à travers nous explique que la loi s'est
bien pour les autres mais pas pour
eux-mêmes nous avons la chance d'être
dans un pays démocratique où nous
pouvons et nous l'avons appelé en début
d'émission exprimer des oppositions
exprimées des revendications mais dans
le cadre de la loi et donc tout ce qui
viendra est bien effectivement
réprimander punir celles et ceux qui ne
respectent pas cette loi va dans le bon
sens donc vous pourriez garder cette
disposition
dans le texte arrivera à l'Assemblée et
bien voyons l'entière durci l'envoyons
l'entièreté du texte parce que encore
une fois ce que j'aime à dire c'est que
oui il y a certains sujets sur lesquels
nous avons une position très ferme
maintenant il faut voir si tout ça est
en bonne harmonie et nous étudierons
l'ensemble de ces dispositions à
l'Assemblée nationale avec mes collègues
et j'insiste pas que de la majorité
l'ensemble de mes collègues
transparisant tout à fait alors on va
passer à la question des violences
conjugales qui étaient à l'ordre du jour
de l'Assemblée nationale et député ont
examiné et voté une proposition de loi
qui crée une aide universelle pour les
victimes de violences conjugales fait
rares donc cette adoption à l'unanimité
compte-rendu de séance avec Marco
pommier
le scrutin éclos pas une seule voix
n'aura manquée 120 pour zéro contre à
l'unanimité les députés se sont
prononcés en faveur du net financière
universelle d'urgence pour les victimes
de violences conjugales une aide sous la
forme d'un prêt à taux zéro ou d'un don
versé par la CAF en fonction de la
situation de la victime il est tellement
difficile pour une femme victime de
violence de partir de quitter son
conjoint quand pendant des années des
mois elle a été humiliée dévalorisée
harceler et donc si vous rajoutez à cela
des difficultés financières et bien ça
devient encore de plus en plus compliqué
et les allers-retours peuvent se
multiplier c'est pourquoi ce texte est
extrêmement important le barème de
l'aide doit encore être précisé par
décret ce soutien financier sera
conditionné au dépôt d'une plainte dans
un commissariat ou une gendarmerie à une
ordonnance de protection ou un
signalement effectué par un personnel de
santé la gauche voulait aller plus loin
à ces 7% de femmes qui aujourd'hui
encore dépose des mains courantes et
pour leur dire que j'ai bon espoir que
vous ne soyez pas exclu de ce dispositif
nous souhaitons l'élargir aux mains
courantes c'est vraiment un geste fort
qui serait fait en la faveur de ces
femmes en 2021 la France enregistrée
plus de 200000 victimes de violences
conjugales cette même année 122 femmes
ont été tuées par leur conjoint ou
ex-conjoint alors le but de ce texte est
de donner aux victimes qui sont sous
l'emprise de leur conjoint violents les
moyens de partir notamment financiers on
a l'impression que ça a été très très
long à mettre en place à être reconnu
est-ce que vous dites il était temps
avec le vote de cette loi j'ai envie de
dire c'est fait c'est fait et c'est fait
de façon transpartisane parce que c'est
vrai qu'on a tendance à considérer
qu'aujourd'hui l'Assemblée nationale
c'est surtout du bruit et des débats qui
sont souvent en vain ce n'est pas vrai
et nous l'avons vu tout au long de cette
semaine avec justement dans ce premier
texte porté par la sénatrice udaïe
Valérie Létard que nous avons accueilli
à l'Assemblée nationale de façon qui
était Président
et nous avons pu voir que aussi bien
l'Assemblée nationale mais aussi entre
les deux chambres et bien quand il
s'agissait du droit des femmes nous ne
parlions que d'une seule voix nous
étions là pour enrichir le texte j'ai
énormément travaillé avec Sandrine
Rousseau avec Arthur de la porte qu'on a
pu voir dans vos images et ce travail ne
s'est pas porté sur le discord
politicienne mais sur nos ambitions
politiques de trouver des compromis
c'est possible mais ce qui est je vous
remercie de le faire aujourd'hui ce qui
est souvent rare c'est que ce n'est pas
souvent retranscrit médiatiquement et
donc on en parle très peu je dois le
dire que nous avons là fait une avancée
extrêmement importante pour les victimes
de violences conjugales parce que
souvent à la violence des mots à la
violence des coûts s'ajoute la violence
économique en général quand une victime
se décide à partir c'est souvent un faux
départ puisque financièrement elle ne
peut pas tenir elle ne peut pas subvenir
à ses propres besoins là de façon très
claire nous mettons en place un
dispositif toi sous la forme d'un prêt
soit sous la forme d'un don encore une
fois ces modalités elles peuvent
paraître basiques mais elles sont
fondamentales alors depuis des années il
y a beaucoup de mesures pour lutter
contre ces violences conjugales mais on
voit quand même que les féminicides se
multiplient dans notre pays et ce que le
législateur n'est pas impuissant le
législateur n'est pas impuissant puisque
je viens de vous relater exactement
comment nous avions maintenant il est
aussi des choses importantes c'est nous
devons continuer à parler de ces sujets
à permettre à cette parole de se libérer
à continuer à ne pas simplement dire je
n'ai pas vu je n'ai pas compris ou ça ne
me regarde pas nous avons tous notre
responsabilité politique mais citoyens
dans leur globalité et je dois le dire
j'ai visité des centres 39 19 ou
effectivement il y a un travail
extrêmement important fondamental fait
par de nombreux par de nombreuses
personnes dans ces centres mais
également des associations sur le
terrain nous devons continuer et ne pas
relâcher et surtout ne pas faire un
enjeu de débat ou de guerre partisane
alors un député a été condamné pour
violence conjugales ils appellent
d'Adrien catenas il a fait son retour la
semaine dernière en commission mais pas
encore en séance publique est-ce que
comme Aurore berger vous souhaitez vous
allez vous opposer à ce qui ce qui
viennent dans l'hémicycle en demandant
par exemple des suspensions de séance ou
déjà moi j'aimerais juste te rappeler
que je suis en commission je siège au
sein de la commission des affaires
sociales là où était censé siéger
monsieur Adrien catenens moi j'ai
entendu effectivement dans les médias ce
jour-là alors que nous étions nous-mêmes
en commission le retour d'Adrien
catenens on a été quelques-uns à se
retourner en disant mais où est-il où
est-il il a été exclu de son groupe donc
il a dû non inscrits il n'était pas là
et on a beaucoup parlé de ce retour
pardon mais pour moi ça reste encore
quelque chose d'hypothétique de
fantasque puisque je ne l'ai pas revu
maintenant on l'a vu en commission
et donc il a c'est super
je l'ai pas croisé dans les couloirs et
on se croise quand même tous un peu mais
s'il revient dans les bicycle qu'est-ce
que vous feriez la question la suivante
mais que va-t-il dire que va-t-il faire
va-t-il pouvoir prendre la parole
va-t-il pouvoir légiférer qu'aurait-il
dit sur la PPL Valérie l'état justement
sur l'aide financière pour les victimes
de violences conjugales je pense
qu'aujourd'hui nous avons cette
responsabilité de la parole politique
qui rappelons-le et quand même bien mis
à mal aujourd'hui et donc j'estime
quadrien katnas a aussi cette
responsabilité de la parole politique
qu'il a pour lui-même mais qu'il a aussi
pour nous tous qu'ils se prenne en main
et qu'il se demande aujourd'hui qu'elles
en jeu quel texte quel discours il se
rend légitimité de pouvoir porter si il
répond qu'il est englise en légitimité
de pouvoir le faire mais très bien à ce
moment-là qui reviennent et qu'on
constate nous-mêmes s'il n'est pas en
capacité je pense qu'il doit peut-être
retourner devant les urnes et redemander
la confiance de ses électeurs
les violences qui concernent nos enfants
et notamment le harcèlement scolaire la
semaine dernière Lucas un collégien
s'est donné la mort car il subissait du
harcèlement à cause de son homosexualité
et cette semaine
le ministre de l'éducation nationale a
été interrogé sur ce drame au Sénat
papendaye ce ministre n'a pu retenir ses
larmes on va regarder cette séquence
il avait seulement 13 ans et toute une
vie devant lui pourtant le 7 janvier
dernier Lucas s'est donné la mort
pourquoi en 2023 en France un gamin
homosexuel en arrive-t-il à se suicider
parce que et croyez-moi je sais trop
bien de quoi je parle il arrive qu'un
envisager qu'une vie de moquerie de
rejet d'exclusion et de haine on arrive
plus à envisager de vie du tout quand un
enfant met fin à ses jours il n'y a pas
de mots
pour dire l'émotion
le chagrin la douleur
il n'y a pas de mots
qu'est-ce que vous voulez que je vous
dise
et donc j'adresse mes pensées les plus
ému
à ses parents à ses proches à ses amis
ce drame montre à quel point la lutte
contre le harcèlement scolaire la lutte
contre l'homophobie parce que
l'homophobie tue oui doit demeurer une
priorité du gouvernement presque à
tableaux cette image d'un ministre en
larmes après ce drame est-ce que ça peut
renforcer la prise de conscience
notamment politique pour lutter contre
l'homophobie et le harcèlement scolaire
les larmes effectivement du ministre de
l'éducation nationale retranscrivent en
fait l'émotion d'une nation entière ce
que j'aimerais rappeler c'est que nous
devons continuer à avoir des mots très
fermes c'est non ça suffit
on ne peut pas subir des harcèlement en
raison de sa couleur de peau de son
orientation sexuelle ou je ne sais quoi
encore oui l'homophobie tue encore en
France et tu de façon extrêmement
violente et de façon plus jeune
aujourd'hui nous devons tous nous lever
sur ce sujet là le dénoncer
surtout ne plus laisser passer nous
avons aujourd'hui la chance d'avoir une
nation qui est unie et soudée sur ses
enjeux continuons à l'être et continuons
surtout à ne plus nous taire à ne pas
nous taire et à continuer à expliquer
que nos enfants doivent pouvoir vivre
librement au regard de leurs aspirations
de leurs ambitions et je rappellerai
quelque chose d'important c'est que
aimer c'est formidable
aimer c'est incroyable pourquoi certains
seraient capables de nous dire que non
tu n'as pas le droit d'aimer non ce que
tu aimes ou ce qui tu aimes ce n'est pas
juste ce n'est pas bien nous devons
rappeler ça aujourd'hui nos enfants sont
capables de ça montrons-leur aussi le
chemin alors la sénatrice mais la niveau
gel rappelé à notre micro les noms des
ministres actuels qui s'étaient opposés
en 2014 au mariage homosexuel Christophe
Béchu Gérard Darmanin l'ancienne
ministre Caroline cailleux qui avait
parlé de ces gens-là est-ce que ces
prises de position ont pu participer au
climat d'homophobie est-ce que c'est
encore admissible où vous dites plus de
propos comme ça non nous devons avoir
une parole ferme et forte je le redis
encore une fois et je l'assume je le
revendique maintenant nous devons aussi
être capable d'accepter que des gens
évoluent on fait de la politique aussi
pour faire que les mentalités évoluent
que oui nous n'en soyons plus à avoir
des propos homophobes ont évolué pour
vous moi je le dis très clairement on
peut pas reprocher à quelqu'un qui a eu
qui a effectivement alors attention ils
ont pas eu des propos hom
ils ont été ils ont été contre ils ont
été contre effectivement le mariage pour
tous soyons très clairs je suis je suis
pour le mariage pour tous maintenant
s'ils ont évolué ils sont revenus sur
leur position tant mieux maintenant à
nous de nous assurer à nous de veiller à
ce que effectivement ce chemin fait soit
un chemin sincère et surtout sans retour
possible allez pour conclure on va
regarder et bien ce qu'il y aura à
l'agenda du Parlement la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
lundi 16 lundi prochain l'atterrissage
le premier atterrissage à l'Assemblée
nationale de la réforme des retraites
puisque Olivier dussobe le ministre du
travail sera auditionné juste après la
présentation du texte en conseil des
ministres et mercredi au Sénat ce sera
également le début des auditions sur la
réforme des retraites avec aussi cette
audition du ministre du Travail Olivier
du socle et puis les sénateurs
interrogeront Pierre Moscovici le
président du Haut Conseil des finances
publiques qui donnera son avis sur cette
réforme des retraites et puis la veille
mardi au Sénat les sénateurs
commenceront à débattre du projet loi
sur les jeux olympiques Paris 2024 avec
notamment des mesures sur la sécurité de
l'événement qui pose question
c'est la fin de cette émission merci
beaucoup friska Thévenot d'avoir été
notre invité merci à tous de l'avoir
suivi et on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine même lieu de même heure ciao
ciao
[Musique]